what thing would you like to leave us
with in order for us to be a success
either on YouTube or any other place the
most important thing I think is just to
believe I've studied more successful
people than most people and just the
work that I do you know Anthony at the
beginning talked about Les Brown and
Warren Buffett and Steve Jobs like what
makes these people so special they're
not that much better than you or me they
just believe in themselves they believe
that where they were born does not need
to be the same place that they end up
they believed that they could create
something special they believed in
themselves to get started they believe
themselves to follow through they
believed in the work that they're doing
and so there's that old quote of whether
you believe you can you can't you're
right I think that's a missing
ingredient for most people